[Music]
god damn i look scruffy today
today we're doing probably the most
uninspired
video idea of all time i'm going through
my instagram account
i don't care i'm genuinely curious
what's at the bottom
i scrolled all the way taking the time
back to this is my first photo december
2011. god damn
that's so cute look at that say aren't
you glad
that's adorable people are still
commenting on this
you guys scroll down on people's
instagram oh you got another embedded
i haven't done this in i can't even
remember i'm glad this is my first photo
that's very
cute this was in sweden in a small
little thai restaurant
and we thought hey let's do a selfie
kiss
and there it is adorable here's a selfie
of me
everything is finally ready moving to
italy today oh my god yeah
that was crazy can't believe how many
times i've moved country
insane i went to germany i don't
remember going to germany
oh right i had my
conference presentation that's right
then i went back to sweden
to do dream hack good photo there felix
very crisp very clear
this is from the stage side pull on the
alerts
it's epic gamer announcement time i can
finally show you
what some of you guys have already
noticed which is
the greatest keyboard of all time
hell yeah pewdiepie keyboard say it with
me
pewdiepie keyboard honestly it's just
it's great i'm so proud of this
aluminum framing it's heavy it feels
sturdy
it's good but the best part about it is
not the
impeccable gaming design it's the
click-back noise
listen to this
yeah yeah you know you want one it feels
good
don't call yourself a gamer unless you
got texturized wsd buttons
wave design throughout rgb
colors lit enough oh i didn't mention
it's wireless with bluetooth file
that's right i can type over here i'm
typing right now
bluetooth 5 baby i assume that's better
than bluetooth 4.
but wait pewdiepie you can't just launch
the most epic keyboard of all time
without of course the most epic
gamer mouse of all time hell yeah
look at this bad boy you see that that's
a bro fish
hell yeah that's detail
each product will be hand kissed
that's a lie but they said they couldn't
do it i don't know if you guys have
tried this type of mouse before where
they have the dotted
to make it lighter i was a bit skeptical
i'm not gonna lie
but i can't even imagine going back to a
regular one now because it's so
comfortable the way it's so
light actually makes a difference i do
really like it
even though it's like oh gamer it is
good
i love it it looks cool too hey jane's
never seen a mouse like this before it
looks great
i'm super proud of these products so if
you want to check out yours
check out the link in the description
but we also have a special offer
13 off right now if you enter the code
pewdiepie you have to enter it
aggressively though otherwise it doesn't
work
on checkout 13 off you're welcome but
wait there was more first 500 to order
the limited case edition that's right
if you buy the pack or both of these
fits in you see i have number one
because i am number one you get one of
these collectors edition
call it what you want cases it'll be
shipped like this basically
you'll get it like you can put it in now
that's nice
it's like a glove look at that
i'm typing right now can't stop me we
ship to over 100 countries worldwide so
wherever you are
as long as you're within those hundred
countries you're good to go
it's pre-order but we're shipping as
early as november 26
so great gift for christmas basically
i'm just happy i finally have my setup
complete
feels good man so what are you waiting
for check out ghostkeyboards.com
pewdiepie link is in the description
super cool
thank you
[Laughter]
2012 dude these are all grown up now
damn that was crazy oh my
oh she looks so tiny thank you
this is before maya started hating me
she will not go near me now
but i guess she stayed next to me oh my
oh
oh my heart
this is from an airplane actually we
brought her on the airplane
all right so now we're in in italy this
is mighty's first car
a really cool first car but god damn it
goes slow
and no air conditioning martial in her
gigantic car it's 40 degrees
yeah italy gets haunted dude i remember
all of these moments
we went to buy ice cream so good gelato
the base it's the best this video feels
like you know when other people show you
their dog
and you're like oh that's so cute
i don't care she's adorable look at her
oh man i took a lot of photos of these
this is going through
the 50 51 galleries or something
whatever how you say 52 yeah yeah this
is
the road the army went through the
italian army through the alps or the
mountains
sorry a masterpiece of military
engineering and boldness
so you go through 51 caves basically it
was amazing
incredible i would love to do that again
the views and everything
it was amazing so all the military
walked through these tiny little caves
that's crazy
i think me and marcia had to go back to
long distance just for a little while
this i remember this was really the time
where it was really anxious because we
didn't have
we obviously came from two different
countries and i didn't have enough money
to really come and visit
so i was really hoping youtube would
work out so i could see my girlfriend
or my future wife back in sweden
damn i look different god damn this is
my daddy
jurgen klopp of course and inc
oh
i can't believe we took a photo like
that
damn instagram filters were different
back in the day man bro
what even is this oh yeah some random
guy just jumped in in the photo
oh yeah we went to venice dude i look
different got a little bit of that
uh youtube chub going on i like that is
this france
yes i say france oh you say france
so sophisticated it sounds better way
back when the sweden guy
simping over italian girl how could i
not look at that
and now they're married this is so fun
yes paris
paris is very pretty just don't look too
close
like this place is gorgeous but it's
filled with tourist traps
why did he travel so much in 2012 i
don't know
missed my old haircut should i go back
guys is it time
thanks so much jim some things never
change she loves to make me ugly i
really appreciate that
oh [ __ ] it's singapore unbelievable time
damn so much happened in 2012 2013. [ __ ]
that was nuts what an adventure dude
crazy so i remember this moment
specifically
because some fans just are never their
fantasies can never be quenched first
they
they sneak a photo of you okay then they
come up to you asking for a selfie it's
like all right
and then they want an autograph but it's
like god
and then what the heck is that look at
my ass so cute
oh what is that demon what happened
there what the [ __ ]
where is this this is singapore again
that was really cool
singapore is strange because there's
such a as a swede i never experienced
this before such a clash
between rich and poor um but both
cultures being really great
i would say because we went to the hotel
and i think we had like a 200 pound
dinner or lunch
and then you go outside literally 500
meters from the hotel we went to this
market with
you get the most incredible food for a
dollar
it was insane yeah it's more from
singapore that was in that hotel is
insane
look at all these photos of maya
[Laughter]
it never stops
oh this is the first photo we ever had
of maya this is my setup back in the day
still keeping it ghetto was [ __ ] not
gonna lie i think we were renting
an airbnb at the time and and the people
tried to like contact my management and
say
you need to pay us because you're
filming at our location
all you can see is a white [ __ ]
background it's ridiculous
oculus 2013 i was one of the first to
have one it was so
fun that was crazy so what's that
seven years and now they're wireless in
another seven years
what's gonna happen is this me and ken
or is it jack
i can't tell i feel it's like a shirt
ken would wear
this is in la dude this is so fun
apparently this selfie was so good i had
to take two of them
some artsy photos in here yeah very
artsy
i realized as i scroll this video is
going to take forever
yeah we got edgar this is the first of
edgar
oh
my baby
i can't tell is this a joke what's the
joke
what the [ __ ] was that carpet disgusting
the whole duck meme where you guys
remember that it's me and my sister they
came to london to support me i was doing
a talk show
this is the same room six years later
a lot has changed so many photos of mega
sleeping
oh he had to get neutered oh
oh 4ag
i feel like this is the part where i was
still a pure soul
you know what i mean there's so much
innocence
still remaining
[Laughter]
oh edgar he was a puppy so he kept
chewing on everything
edgar and his new boyfriend the printer
for some reason i did this photoshop
oh what i haven't seen yet
[Laughter]
that's crazy i haven't seen this this is
new orleans
so pretty such a pretty city disneyland
with ken
and captain sparkle
oh my god there it is damn
this photo is really
crazy story i think i said it many times
but
i was doing south park dream come true
right
they want me to do voice acting for
south park
and south park the production has an
insane work cycle
the way they keep things so relevant is
that they work
to the day of the launch of the episode
and
they decided to do it make it a two-part
series i thought i was only doing one
episode
and i was flying i had a trip booked for
japan so they're like we need you for
to do a couple lines for the next
episode but i'm like but i'm going on
holiday
so i guess i brought i brought my uh
whole equipment
just to shoot it in this ryokan uh
which is this traditional japanese inn
where the bulls are literally
paper thin and i had to yell these south
park lines
but on top of that i got the worst flu
of my life
i it was i couldn't move
i physically couldn't move so i remember
just going out with
whatever strength i had left finding the
nearest
shop that sold medicine i went in and i
said
she gave me a bottle i don't know how
many tablets
i don't know how what for but i took him
and i shot those 10 lines and i shot him
live with trey parker too
it was on the phone it was such an
insane experience i'm so glad i had that
experience
i hate myself for totally ruining it i
wish i had more confidence back then
like i have now
but it's a crazy story oh
i was still innocent back here not all
heroes wear caves when i wear headbutts
this would be like an ironic meme in
this age
back in there i was like sweetest damn
post ever
i'm 14 and this is deep right i got sick
in japan again
amazing and i liked my own photo this is
where it all went dark
damn i got fat god damn she got fat
holy [ __ ]
my sister got married here's a photo of
me
the book signings can't zoom in on it
i signed 3 000 books and one of them was
a penis
please if you have the penis i would
love i would love to see it please
post on the reddit if you have the penis
simp
[Music]
why are people still commenting on old
photos it's a promo for the walking dead
i think it took two hours to get that on
it was pretty crazy
i remember this this is on the way to
shoot scare pewdiepie and i posted we're
going to la
and then when we landed there was a tmc
waiting at the airport because i had
posted this photo saying i'm going to la
this is during the shoot of scare
pewdiepie we spent the entire day
i think the shot was delayed like they
needed to trick me and throw me off we
spent the entire day just shooting fake
shots
i'm not even joking we went all around
la
just shooting fake shots it was so
weird i can't explain just how strange
that was to realize afterwards wait that
was
the whole fake oh yeah i met stephen
colbert
it was really cool a promo for my book a
ton of promo for my bag
i got to work some really cool people
for that i really enjoy that
what a journey man i went through so
much stuff this
is san francisco i mean i maybe i'm bad
at understanding
but i feel like they didn't explain to
me what was about to happen i had no
idea
i thought i was just doing a regular
signing but they said hey
these people had to wait a little longer
to get your book so
it'd be cool if we just you just like go
and
do something in front of these people
and i'm like okay sure
enter this room just completely packed
with fans
i'm awkward okay i'm comfortable behind
the camera but like
just entering this room people screaming
it was crazy
for me only so much happiness and joy
and wondering is so cool
it's the star wars premiere yeah
and then things got weird i
remember 2016.
i had snails for some reason everyone
remember that
legendary photo right there
[Laughter]
i went on cold and it's crazy also very
cool dude
i was so nervous god damn it i wish i
had more confidence back then
i would kill it now conan have me back
please i met ryan reynolds in the
screen room he's the only celebrity i've
ever asked for a selfie and i still feel
bad after hand for asking for it
but he was really nice about it and i
did him dirty ryan
if you're watching i'm sorry i had two
photos i could pick from
one where i look good and one where you
look good but there wasn't one where we
both look good and i did you dirty i'm
sorry
you still look really good though don't
get me wrong midtree parker
how cool is that one of my idols huge
inspiration
i said this before but trey parker uh
still working on south park still
keeping things fresh after so many years
i really admire that
i would only hope to have a career like
him so cool and mad as well of course
went to japan again for the hundredth
time
it's always so fun i was super into
jogging i would i think i would run like
miles
10 20 kilometers i would run it was
crazy i don't know what was wrong with
me i could never do that today
but i remember jogging in tokyo or like
if you're into jogging and you go to a
different country and you jog in that
place it's such a great way to
just see places you wouldn't normally
see and i i remember i loved that about
tokyo to just run through tokyo it was
so cool
how sweet is this my so my my dad knew i
was into jogging
so he came with me when i was in sweden
and he wore the petey farmer she's so
nice
my nephew legendary photo right there
that was fun that was really fun i met
so many cool dudes thanks to youtube
it's crazy
oh i met shadow lady before and i didn't
even realize that what the [ __ ]
i met vickstar i didn't even know that
what the [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
ken flew over to support my man
i can smell it we're close
there it is oh my god
i can smell it that was crazy
i can't believe we did that i had to
jump in the water and swim back to shore
but i was fully clothed with boots
and i was just like well i hope i make
it
[Laughter]
hey where it all started the japanese
whiskey
oh no don't do it damn so many photos i
completely forgot about
this is uh malaysia come back
come back please come back malaysia's
super cool
what the actual hey launch of two for
simulator
the most relevant game of all time it's
still doing really well
it's such a great game oh sleepy
sleepy remember never forgetty
this is scary pretty pie season two rest
in peace
sometimes i have to i tell people about
scare pete what happened and scared
pewdiepie season two
just so i feel like i'm not crazy it
happened i went through all these crazy
[ __ ] you don't
like because they uh they um amped it up
all the craziness in season two
and uh it's just wild to go through
these insane experiences that
i can't have no i don't even like i
can't show it
hey i met eli and ethan oh sweet sleigh
babe
one of the greatest photos of all time
of me right there
another another greatest photo of all
time
right there before i was outlawed sony
sent me a playstation
uh for sony send me a playstation 5 i'm
begging you
i want to play demon souls hell yeah
while you were busy playing minecraft i
studied the blade
i wish i was playing minecraft
[Music]
oh how the tables have turned no the
water smelled like ass but it was nice
and hot yeah it was sulfur
it was crazy it was pretty gross i can't
believe i did that
there's a strange photo that exists
we got doggie or a hedgehog i had the
beard
okay i look weird i met with that
aggretsuko
that was so cool the series is really
good they came out after
we didn't realize it was going to be big
it was so good japan during cherry
blossom
i think this is meguro 2018 when i
finally
rediscovered my love for literature i
would bring a book everywhere
ah take me back take me back i want to
go back
i want to go back and there it is
finally tied the knot is that the
expression i don't care if it's cringe i
like my own photo
over a year ago now i know it's cliche
to say
but it really was the happiest day of my
life actually i've been posting a fair
bit lately so why don't you
follow me over on the instagram that was
so fun i can't believe i spent 40
minutes
uncut at least going through all of that
side will cut it down sorry sorry this
will be awful daddy thank you for
joining me
or making this crazy journey that i had
unbelievable
for supporting and watching my videos um
that's really cool
i enjoyed that a lot hope you enjoyed as
well look at the graph
and i'll see you guys tomorrow brofist
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we looked far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings